what does a modern family look like the
Netherlands could become the first
country in the world to allow a child to
have more than two legal parents
families nowadays are complicated gay
couples and infertile couples often have
children with the help of surrogates or
friends meaning three or more people may
consider themselves the parents here in
the Netherlands they're talking about
changing the law to reflect the way that
some of these new families actually work
there are thousands of these families in
the country although no one is quite
sure how many but does growing up in a
non-traditional family have any impact
on the well-being of children or their
parents four years ago papaya and his
boyfriend Evo decided they wanted to
have a child after exploring all the
options available they asked their
friend Jeanette if she would be the mom
in 2015
Jeanette gave birth to their daughter
Kate the three adults share parental
responsibilities
but in the Netherlands like most other
countries a child can only have two
legal parents in 2013 California passed
a law allowing more than two parents in
some cases a few provinces in Canada
also allow it but no country has adopted
the practice nationwide
how did you decide you wanted to have a
family we had this really deep desire
keep your father's in the end I think
this was sort of a last chance also for
us and at some point we decided to ask
you know if he wanted to be become a
rainbow family with us that's what
something like that what do you think I
was very glad he acted Jeanette lives
close by and two-year-old Cates puts her
time equally between the two homes I was
living on the sort of life in it I was
very happy with that live very nice with
Trevor laws I go out a lot then I
imagined the life with two fathers and
child and it was such another feeling
inside the fort Kate was born the pine
EVO and Jeanette drew up a contract
detailing how their family would work so
what we were doing is the first thing is
that we should always act in the
interest of the child that's number one
and so also our number one here in this
agreement so if we don't agree on stuff
well maybe we start disliking each other
a lot or maybe we split even though I so
wrote all these things down in order to
sort of prevent that things we start
going wrong it's also finance the
distance between the two houses shall
always live from cycling distance from
each other so a reasonable distance it's
it sounds complicated maybe with
hello head hey Abby that dog he hello
head the family planned for their child
in more detail than most straight
parents the problem is under current law
their plans are not legally binding the
issue effects Evo the most because he's
not Kate's biological father when you
worried that because you weren't about
biological father that she would have a
different relationship to you I really
thought about that like when she is
there or hit that well by then we didn't
know it was a she of course how would
she react to a non-biological parent and
because we with the three of us we are
so equal we have the same amount of
attention or so for her there's no
difference what are some of the concrete
legal problems that you can encounter
because you're not only registered as a
legal parent if I want to go on holiday
with her without the time unit then I
can be stopped at the border and they
can tell me like you're you are now
[Music]
kidnapping a child legally and nothing
to take emotionally I'm everything okay
multiple studies have shown that
same-sex parents are just as likely to
raise well-adjusted children as
heterosexual couples but multi parent
families are a relatively new phenomenon
skeptics worry that having more than two
parents in a family could be confusing
for the child and also that having more
than two parents might be more likely to
lead to breakups and ultimately possibly
lawsuits researchers at the University
of Amsterdam have carried out a
long-term study on families with more
than two parents what does the research
say about the effects of being in multi
parent households on children we see
that these children doing as well as the
children in the and a comparison group
of father mother families so they are
not showing more or more or less problem
behavior and they are also regarding the
well-being and doing as well as the
children in the comparison group of etic
to parent families while the Dutch
government deliberates over whether to
change the law the reality is that multi
parent families exist and are becoming
more common loving families able to care
for their children should be legally
represented as such no matter what their
shape or size
you
you